[Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a INTERNXT,
un servicio de almacenamiento en la nube muy
pero que muy interesante.
Quedaos con este nombre, INTERNXT: Arranquemos.]
Asia-Pacífico se ha convertido en la región
más importante del mundo.
Y tal y como ya os hemos contado, en la pugna
por el control entre Estados Unidos, sus aliados,
y China no sólo importa quién tiene más
o menos bases militares, sino también quién
emplea mejor sus armas y sabe sacar mejor
provecho de los nuevos avances tecnológicos.
Esta es, de hecho, una carrera paralela a
la propia escalada militar que está viviendo
la región.
Y sí, puede que Estados Unidos siga muy por
delante, pero amigos, los chinos tienen sus
propias cartas.
(Históricamente el ejército chino ha tenido
serios problemas para equiparse con armas
avanzadas que llegado el caso les permitiera
enfrentarse de tú a tú con enemigos tan
fuertes como Estados Unidos.
Precisamente por eso, para suplir esa limitación,
la estrategia de China ha pasado esencialmente
por una apuesta por la cantidad, esto es por
disponer de un número muy grande de tropas
que le permitiera proteger sus fronteras,
actuar como disuasión ante cualquier posible
ataque y operar en un terreno próximo.)
Es algo que vimos, en cierta forma, durante
la Guerra de Corea, cuando un enorme ejército
formado por unos 800.000 “voluntarios”
chinos fueron a la guerra para ayudar a las
tropas del dictador norcoreano Kim Il Sung.
Claro que en la guerra moderna, una guerra
dominada por la comunicación, los satélites
y los ataque quirúrgicos, la cantidad ha
ido perdiendo cada vez más y más y más
relevancia.
Ojo, hablo de la guerra, no de la postguerra…
Eso como se vió en Irak o en Afganistán
es una cuestión muy diferente.
El caso es que con rivales tecnológicamente
tan avanzados como Estados Unidos, Corea del
Sur, Japón o Australia el ejército chino
no le ha quedado otra que ponerse las pilas.
El Ejército Popular de Liberación lleva
años inmerso en un proceso de cambio cuyo
objetivo es darle la vuelta de arriba a abajo.
Transitar desde la idea del soldado como “corazón
del ejército”, a la tecnología como núcleo
esencial de las fuerzas armadas.
La fecha para lograrlo también está fijada:
el año 2049.
Pero, evidentemente no hay recursos para todo.
De hecho, ya os contamos en un pasado vídeo
que la diferencia de presupuesto militar entre
Estados Unidos y China puede ser mucho más
grande de lo que pensamos a primera vista.
Así que, en otras palabras, los líderes
chinos han tenido que escoger en qué tipo
de guerra quieren destacar.
Así que la pregunta que seguro, seguro todos
os hacéis es: ¿Por dónde van los tiros?
¿Cuáles son exactamente los tipos de armas
con las que los líderes chinos aspiran a
tener la hegemonía de Asia-Pacífico?
¿Qué demonios tienen en mente?
(Básicamente el régimen chino está apostando
por la superioridad aérea convencional con
tecnología de sigilo así como por las conocidas
como armas de nuevo concepto.
Las armas de nuevo concepto es una tipología
de armamento que a su vez se divide en tres
grandes subgrupos:
Primero, las armas de energía dirigida, como
las tecnologías de pulso electromagnético
o las armas láser,
Segundo las armas de información, como los
virus informáticos y sistemas de hackeo.
Y tercero las armas biológicas o químicas,
como por ejemplo las desarrolladas con virus
editados genéticamente.)
[Stop!
Qué ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
No, esto último no es en absoluto ninguna
referencia al SARS-CoV-2.
Que nos conocemos...]
Pues bien, el caso es que los científicos
militares chinos llevan años trabajando en
todos y cada uno de estos 3 campos con una
idea: crear un novedoso sistema militar que
sea capaz de atacar de la forma más eficiente,
multiplicar los daños e, incluso, ser invisible.
Muchos de vosotros, quizás nunca hayáis
oído hablar de algunas de las armas que os
vamos a mostrar.
Porque no, este vídeo no va de portaaviones,
fragatas, tanques ni de ninguna otra cosa
que recuerde esencialmente al siglo XX.
Atentos.
[Pero, antes de continuar con el vídeo me
gustaría hablaros un momento de INTERNXT.
Como sabéis en VisualPolitik trabajamos con
mucha, muchísima documentación y nos preocupa
mucho la seguridad y la privacidad.
Por eso esta empresa nos ha llamado muchísimo
la atención.
INTERNXT es un servicio de almacenamiento
en la nube que no solo te permite organizar
mejor tus documentos, sino que además es
mucho más seguro que los servicios en la
nube de las big tech.
Pero, ¿cuál es la diferencia?
Pues veréis, INTERNXT encripta todos tus
datos y no guarda tu clave de encriptación.
Para que nos entendamos, esto significa que
solo tú tienes acceso a tus datos.
Nadie más.
Interesante, ¿no os parece?
INTERNXT quiere convertirse en una alternativa
para almacenar datos en la nube, centrada,
sobre todo, en la seguridad y la confidencialidad
de toda tu información.
Y además tienen varios planes de suscripción
que se adaptan a las necesidades de cada usuario.
¿Pero sabéis qué es lo mejor?
Que solo por haber visto este vídeo tendrás
un mes gratis al suscribirte a su plan de
2 TB.
Así que no pierdas la oportunidad de probar
INTERNXT con esta oferta exclusiva, introduciendo
el cupón VISUALPOLITIK cuando elijas tu plan.
Os dejamos el enlace a su web en la descripción.
Dicho esto continuemos.
(LAS ARMAS DE ENERGÍA DIRIGIDA)
Seguro, seguro que todos habéis oído hablar
de las armas láser.
Me juego un brazo a que sí.
Es una idea que puede parecer sacada de Star
Wars pero que ya existe en el mundo militar
y que, en diferentes fases experimentales,
está ya siendo probada por ejércitos como
los de Estados Unidos, Rusia y sí, también
China.
Sin embargo, las armas láser son tan solo
uno de los tipos de armas que podemos encontrar
dentro de una categoría más amplia: la de
las armas de energía dirigida.
(Las armas de energía dirigida son un tipo
de armas de última generación que utilizan
“proyectiles” que no son sólidos, como
por ejemplo láser o plasma.
O dicho de otra forma, no disparan proyectiles
tal y como los conocemos normalmente, lo que
tiene importantes ventajas:
Por un lado, potencialmente pueden ser mucho
más baratas una vez son producidas porque
no necesitan munición, y por otro lado, hoy
por hoy el ataque no puede ser detenido por
ningún tipo de escudo o de sistema.
Además, son armas muy precisas que generan
menos deflagraciones y daños colaterales.
¿El problema?
Que debido precisamente a estos factores -bajo
coste y alta dificultad para evitar el ataque
- son también armas más peligrosas que las
convencionales, especialmente si en el futuro
consiguen dar el salto evolutivo que los ejércitos
de las grandes potencias están buscando.)
En el caso de China, en 2017 el país dio
a conocer un sistema de armas láser llamado
Silent Hunter, que traducido al español significa
“Cazador Silencioso”.
Este sistema ha sido desarrollado por la empresa
Poly Technologies, perteneciente al grupo
empresarial público China Poly Group Corporation.
El artefacto consta de un cañón láser montado
sobre un camión y alimentado por electricidad.
Utilizando la máxima potencia el láser llega
a tener un alcance de 4 kilómetros sin apenas
perder efectividad destructiva.
Para que os hagáis una idea de su potencia,
es capaz de penetrar cinco placas de acero
de dos milímetros de grosor cada una a 800
metros de distancia, o una sola placa de cinco
milímetros si hablamos de un kilómetro.
Esto, traducido a la vida real, implicaría
que, en distancias cortas, el Silent Hunter
sería capaz de comprometer incluso a vehículos
blindados ligeros en un hipotético, a la
vez que improbable, combate terrestre.
Ahora bien, la pregunta clave, ¿para qué
demonios quiere China este sistema?
Pues, en principio no parece que la idea sea
ofensiva, sino más bien todo lo contrario.
[Aunque con matices… Porque, bueno, la enemistad
entre India y China podría terminar haciéndola
protagonista.]
Pero no nos desviemos.
Por un lado este láser podría ser enormemente
útil como defensa anti-drones de baja altura.
Siempre y cuándo olvidemos que con un alcance
de un kilómetro a máxima potencia, y que
los drones militares más avanzados pueden
volar a unos 15.000 metros de altura, este
láser tiene hoy por hoy una aplicación muy
limitada en materia defensiva.
(Según Pekín, por ahora su utilidad pasa
por proteger instalaciones sensibles o incluso
eventos multitudinarios del vuelo de drones
no autorizados.
Drones que, por ejemplo, pudieran suponer
una amenaza terrorista.
Aunque, lo cierto es que en alguna ocasión
Estados Unidos ya se ha quejado de que China
ha utilizado este u otro sistema similar para
apuntar a los pilotos estadounidenses de aviones
C-130 Hércules mientras volaban en Djibouti
- donde China tiene su única base militar
en el extranjeo - causando heridas menores
en los ojos a algunos de estos pilotos.)
¿Ensayos?
Sea como sea y tenga el futuro que tenga,
esta arma láser no es la única arma de energía
dirigida que China está desarrollando.
Fijaos.
(China podría haber probado una nueva arma
electromagnética: Informe - The Defense Post)
Pero… ¿Qué diantres es esto de un artefacto
electromagnético exactamente?
Pues bien, hay dos formas principales de usar
la fuerza electromagnética en la guerra.
Una más espectacular que otra.
Y en ambos tipos China ha logrado ya importantes
avances.
Por un lado están los ataques de pulso electromagnético,
que mediante el envío de un pulso, similar
a cuando se produce una fuerte llamarada solar,
son capaces de poner en jaque todo el sistema
eléctrico de un país, así como todo aquello
que utilice electricidad o geoposicionamiento.
[No, esto no es ninguna teoría conspiranoica
ni ninguna idea alocada, es realidad.]
¿Pero cómo creéis que se podría conseguir
de forma artificial esta energía electromagnética
tan descomunal?
¿Alguna idea?
3,2,1… Pues por ejemplo mediante armas nucleares.
Concretamente a través de una tecnología
particular de misiles y la tecnología de
la bomba de hidrógeno o termonuclear, se
puede conseguir provocar un enorme pulso electromagnético
si se detona a gran altitud sobre el lugar
del ataque.
En teoría este tipo de ataques no tienen
los efectos negativos y destructivos de un
ataque nuclear convencional, pero el caos
que pueden llegar a provocar es inmenso.
(China tiene la capacidad de un “primer
golpe” que funda la red eléctrica de EE.UU.
con un arma de pulso electromagnético - Forbes)
¿Impresionados?
Pues esperad a ver lo que es capaz de hacer
China desde un simple barco.
¿Los protagonistas?
Los cañones de riel electromagnéticos.
Y los que más sabéis de esto diréis…
pero Alberto, ¡si eso no es nada nuevo!
Y es verdad, la idea conceptual es bastante
antigua, data de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
[de hecho tenemos un vídeo dedicado al tema
en nuestro canal de Megaprojekts, echadle
un ojo].
La diferencia entre los de esa época y los
actuales es su aplicación y, obviamente,
sus mejoras en fuerza y precisión.
En el caso de China, en 2018 apareció en
Wuhan un enorme cañón de riel electromagnético
montado en la proa del buque Haiyang Shan.
(Este tipo de arma no es exactamente un arma
de energía dirigida, ya que dispara un proyectil,
pero lo hace montándolo en dos rieles conductores
paralelos cargados con una cantidad enorme
de electricidad, lo que crea un campo magnético.
Esto permite que el proyectil salga del cañón
a velocidades supersónicas gracias a la fuerza
de Lorentz.
De esta forma multiplica la destrucción en
blancos con cinturones acorazados como por
ejemplo los buques de guerra.)
Precisamente por esto China lo ha probado
a bordo de un barco.
Pekín cree que este arma le puede dar superioridad
naval a su Marina.
Y claro, evidentemente una superioridad numérica
y también tecnológica es clave para que
China pueda cumplir su sueño de controlar
los mares de la región Asia-Pacífico, sobre
todo el de la China Meridional.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto seguro que
os estáis preguntando por el resto de armas
de las que os íbamos a hablar en este vídeo.
Pues bien, vamos allá.
(LA GUERRA DEL FUTURO ESTÁ EN EL AIRE)
¿Os acordáis del
mítico bombardero estadounidense F-117 Nighthawk?
Ese avión tan extraño que cautivó a los
amantes de la aviación militar y cuya principal
característica era ser el primer bombardero
“invisible” del mundo.
Apuesto a que sí.
Pues bien, la tecnología del sigilo ya no
es algo tan exclusivo.
De hecho, muchos países con programas más
o menos potentes de desarrollo de aviones
militares ya han adoptado esta tecnología,
total o parcialmente.
Y sí, China es también uno de ellos.
(Este es el caso del caza Chengdu J-20, que
sin las sinuosas formas geométricas del F-117
es también un avión “invisible” o furtivo
de quinta generación.
O al menos eso decía Pekín hasta hace poco.
La cuestión es que este es el primer caza
con tecnología de sigilo desarrollado íntegramente
en el gigante asiático.
Un caza diseñado supuestamente para competir
con otros tres cazas furtivos avanzados que
están actualmente en servicio: los F-22 y
F-35 estadounidenses, y el Sukhoi Su-57 ruso.)
Hoy por hoy, sin embargo, son muchos expertos
en la materia los que coinciden en que el
J-20 no reúne los requisitos necesarios como
para ser considerado un caza de quinta generación,
sino que se situaría en algún punto entre
la cuarta generación y la 4,5.
En cualquier caso, lo que más se discute
sobre este aparato no es eso, sino cómo se
desarrolló.
Concretamente, existen muchas sospechas de
que tiene detrás toda una historia de espionaje
militar a los programas estadounidenses de
los cazas invisibles F-35 y F-22.
Sí, tal cual como lo oís.
Lockheed Martin, la compañía desarrolladora
de estos dos modelos, está convencida de
que hackers chinos robaron documentos técnicos
del F-35 en 2007, y también penetraron en
la red de un subcontratista australiano del
programa.
También están seguros de que el modelo chino
incluye tecnología robada del programa F-22.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué se basan?
Pues bien, según fuentes estadounidenses,
el sistema de sensores del J-20 es casi clavado
al del F-22.
Y no solo eso, parece copiar al F-35 en cosas
tan importantes como el radar o las calibraciones
del motor.
El robo de tecnología militar occidental
por parte de China ha sido, durante mucho
tiempo, más que una sospecha, prácticamente
un secreto a voces.
En este caso incluso Edward Snowden - que
no está precisamente bien visto por el gobierno
estadounidense - confirma que efectivamente,
China robó muchos terabytes de datos de información
clasificada sobre el F-35.
(Nuevos documentos de Snowden revelan que
los chinos están detrás del hackeo al F-35
- The Diplomat)
Amigos, uno de los sueños militares que Pekín
siempre ha tenido es romper la brecha aérea
con Estados Unidos.
(Hoy por hoy, los expertos consideran que
las características de este avión son muy
inferiores a las de sus competidores estadounidenses,
y que no tiene la capacidad de ganar en un
enfrentamiento abierto.
Eso sí, su propia evolución supone un paso
adelante decisivo para la industria militar
china.
Es por así decirlo su primera gran incursión.)
Una incursión con una importante ventaja:
sin el F-35, para Taiwán podría resultar
muy complicado contener un ataque masivo con
este avión.
Precisamente por eso, las autoridades taiwanesas
llevan años pidiendo a Estados Unidos que
les permitan comprar el F-35, pero la respuesta
de los americanos ha sido dar largas o hablar
de un leasing que, de momento, no llega.
(Las ventas de aviones de combate a Taiwán
y el complejo equilibrio de poder entre Estados
Unidos y China - Channel News Asia
Taiwán quería cazas F-35B con capacidad
de aterrizaje y despegue vertical corto para
preservar su capacidad aérea en caso de ataques
sorpresa del EPL en aeródromos taiwaneses
que inhabiliten las pistas.
[...] Estos intentos por negociar la venta,
sin embargo, se vieron obstaculizados con
la Administración de Obama, que en su lugar
ofreció el paquete de actualización del
F-16 a Taiwán.)
No hay forma.
Parece que Washington no quiere abrir el melón
político que supondría que Taipei tuviera
sus propios cazas F-35.
De momento, la respuesta americana ha sido
mover de vez en cuando portaaviones a la zona
cargados con estos aviones, pero los taiwaneses
no tienen la seguridad de que, ante un ataque
real chino, Estados Unidos entre en combate,
y por ese motivo, lógicamente, quieren tener
sus propios F-35.
Pero ojo porque el caza Chengdu J-20 no es
la única “amenaza sigilosa” china.
(China también está trabajando en el desarrollo
de un avanzado modelo de dron, el WJ-700.
Junto con el dron invisible Sky Hawk, China
podría realizar reconocimientos en entornos
hostiles y luego atacar desde gran altitud.
El WJ-700 es un salto cualitativo brutal en
el programa de drones chino, ya que es el
único dron de gran altitud, alta velocidad
y largo rango capaz de ejecutar misiones de
ataque.
En concreto, puede realizar ataques de precisión
aire-superficie en múltiples situaciones,
algo que lo pone casi a la altura de los drones
estadounidenses más modernos.)
La ventaja que le daría este tipo de armas
a Pekín para operar en el extranjero podría
cambiar en el futuro la estrategia militar
y diplomática de Pekín.
Solo el tiempo dirá.
Amigas y amigos de VisualPolitik, estas son
solo unas pocas de las muchas nuevas armas
con las que China quiere dar el golpe en la
mesa en el futuro.
Hay muchísimas más, de todas las formas
y colores, incluido un sistema de guerra espacial.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
China está desarrollando un sistema ASAT
de destrucción de satélites mediante cohetes
espaciales, una capacidad que ya tenía la
Unión Soviética durante la Guerra Fría.
Y luego los temas de virus modificados genéticamente
o la ciberguerras, ámbitos de los que seguro
hablaremos más adelante.
China sigue muy lejos de Estados Unidos, y
evidentemente los norteamericanos tienen sus
propios programas de armas tecnológicamente
avanzadas.
Pero la apuesta china está sobre la mesa
y en ella las armas de energía dirigida,
los cazas de quinta generación y los drones
avanzados juegan un papel clave.
También los misiles supersónicos, con los
que las fuerzas armadas chinas esperan dejar
fuera de combate por obsoleta a la mismísima
marina norteamericana.
(China prueba nueva capacidad espacial con
misiles hipersónicos El lanzamiento en agosto
de cohetes con capacidad nuclear dio la vuelta
al mundo y tomó por sorpresa a la inteligencia
estadounidense.
FT)
Pero dicho esto, turno para ti: ¿Crees que
China logrará equipararse a la fuerza de
Estados Unidos en Asia Pacífico?
Déjanos tu comentario aquí abajo, y si te
ha gustado este vídeo no olvides darle like
y suscribirte a VisualPolitik si aún no lo
has hecho.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.